Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Whenever we look at these amazing research papers on physical simulations,
it is always a joy, seeing people discussing them in the comment section.
However,
one thing that caught my attention is that some people comment about how things
look and not on how things move in these papers, which is fair enough.
And to this end,
I will devote this episode to talk about a few amazing techniques in light
transport simulations. But first things first,
when talking about physics simulations,
we are talking about the technique that computes, how things move.
And then we typically run a light simulation program that computes how things
look. The two are completely independent,
which means that it is possible that the physical behavior of bread breaking
here is correct, but the bread itself does not look perfectly realistic.
The second part depends on the quality of the light simulation and the
materials used there.
We can create such an image by simulating the path of millions and millions of
light rays.
And initially this image will look noisy and as we add more and more res,
this image was slowly clean up over time.
If we don't have a well optimized program,
this can take from hours to days to compute,
we can speed up this process by carefully choosing where to shoot these rays.
And this is a technique that is called important sampling,
but then around 1993,
an amazing paper appeared by the name bi-directional pass tracing that
proposed that we don't just start building light paths from one direction,
but two instead one from the camera and one from the light source and
then connect them.
This significantly improved the efficiency of these light simulations. However,
it opened up a new can of worms.
There are many different ways of connecting these paths,
which leads to mathematical difficulties.
For instance, we have to specify the probability of a light path forming,
but what do we do if there are multiple ways of producing this light path,
there will be multiple probabilities.
What do we do with all this stuff to address this?
Eric Veatch described the magical algorithm in his thesis and thus multiple
important sampling was born.
I can say without exaggeration that this is one of the most powerful techniques
in all for the realistic rendering research,
what multiple important sampling or from now on MIS in short
does is combined these multiple sampling techniques in a way that accentuates
the strength of each of them. For instance,
you can see the image created by one sampling technique here,
and the image from a different one here,
both of them are quite noisy, but if we combine them with MIS,
we get this instead in the same amount of time and much smoother,
less noisy image.
In many cases,
this can truly bring down the computation times from several hours to several
minutes, absolute witchcraft later,
even more advanced techniques appeared to accelerate the speed of these light
simulation programs.
For instance,
it is now not only possible to compute light transport between points in space,
but between a point and a beam. Instead,
you see the evolution of an image using this forearm beam based technique.
This way we can get rid of the point based noise and get a much,
much more appealing rendering process.
Delete author of these beam paper is [inaudible] who three years later
ended up being the head of the rendering group at the amazing Disney research
lab. Around that time.
He also hired me to work with him at Disney on a project I can talk about,
which was an incredible and life-changing experience.
And I will be forever grateful for his kindness, by the way,
he's now a professor at the Dartmouth university and just keeps pumping out one
killer paper after another.
So as you might have guessed,
if it is possible to compute light transport between two points,
the point and a beam later, it became possible to do this between two beams.
None of these are for the faint of the heart, but it works really well,
but there is a huge problem.
These techniques work with different dimensionalities or in other words,
they estimate the final result so differently that they cannot be combined with
multiple important sampling.
That is indeed a problem because all of these have completely different
strengths and weaknesses.
And now hold onto your papers because we have finally arrived to the main paper
of this episode.
It bears the name UPB P which stands for unifying points, beams,
and paths,
and it formulates multiple important sampling between all of these different
kinds of flight, transport simulations.
Basically what we can do with this is through every advanced simulation program
we can think of together and outcomes,
a super powerful version of them that combines all their strengths and
nullifies, nearly all of their weaknesses.
It is absolutely unreal here.
You see four completely different algorithms running, and as you can see,
they are noisy and smooth at very different places.
They are good at computing, different kinds of light transport.
And now hold onto your papers because this final result with the UPB P technique
is this wow light transport on steroids.
While we look at some more results, I will note that in my opinion,
this is one of the best papers ever written in light transport research.
The crazy thing is that I hardly ever hear anybody talk about it.
If any paper would deserve a bit more attention.
So I hope this video will help with that.
And I would like to dedicate this video to Jaroslav.
Chovanec the first author of this absolutely amazing paper who has tragically
passed away a few months ago in my memories.
I think of him as the true King of multiple important sampling.
And I hope that now you do,
to note that MIS is not limited to light transport algorithms.
It is a general concept that can be used together with a mathematical technique
called Monte-Carlo integration,
which is used pretty much everywhere from finding out what an electromagnetic
field looks like to financial modeling and much, much more.
If you have anything to do with Monte-Carlo integration,
please read Eric breaches thesis and this paper.
And if you feel that it is a good fit,
try to incorporate multiple important sampling into your system.
You'll be glad you did. Also,
we have recorded my lectures of a master level course on light transport
simulations at the technical university of Vienna. In this course,
we're at such a light simulation program from scratch and it is available free
of charge for everyone, no strings attached.
So make sure to click the link in the video description to get started.
Additionally,
I have implemented a small one dimensional example of MIS if you wish to pick it
up and try it.
That's also available in the video description while talking about the technical
university of Vienna, we are hiring for a PhD and a postdoc position.
The call here about lighting simulation for architectural design is advised by
my PhD advisor, Mika Vima, who I highly recommend apply. Now,
if you feel qualified, the link is in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.